marvel's avengers makes you feel like a
marvel's avengers
whoa thought i was watching ign there
for a second but no no no
this is the heavy spoilers show show
show as always i'm your host definition
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down everything that you
need to know about the new game at
marvel's avengers
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't played it yet and don't want
anything ruined then i recommend that
you turn off now
if you loved this video 3000 then please
drop a thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to the
channel for breakdowns like this every
day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into marvel's
avengers
okay so avengers opens on a day which is
a celebration of the infamous group
they've just unveiled a new hq in san
francisco
along with a brand new heli carrier
known as the chimera
the chimera is the first craft of its
kind and we learned that it's powered by
a new energy source
known as the terrigen crystal the
celebrations quickly turned to frowns
faster than when thanos said you should
have gone for the head and a terrorist
group led by taskmaster descend on the
party
destroying the golden gate bridge in the
process to make matters worse the
chimera
explodes and the crystal releases
terrigen mist which transforms the crowd
of people into inhumans
captain america is seemingly killed in
the explosion and the avengers are
blamed for everything
yes everything even all of 2020
we pretty much get an end game-esque
five-year time jump
and learn that under the testimonial of
bruce banner the group decided to go
their separate ways
and a company called aim have stepped in
to find a cure for what they call the
inhuman disease
led by george talton they aim to save
the world
but throughout the game we learn that
they're actually the bad guys
spoiler alert we discover that kamala
khan a young teen was infected by the
terrorism mist during a day
and because of this she's given the
power of elasticity this allows your
body to be able to stretch and grow
and it's a bit like one of my body parts
i can stretch and grow
as well i shouldn't have said that in
the video i'm sorry now after she's
given leaked info about aim from someone
known as tiny dancer
we pretty much follow her as she
uncovers the truth about that day
whilst getting the band back together
now from the off i will say that whether
you think the game itself is good or not
the storyline is absolutely brilliant
and it's pretty much a must buy if
you're a marvel maniac
there's a lot of flashes of civil war in
here and that's my favorite comic book
run ever
so i really appreciated the approach of
the characters that showed them for who
they really were
empires are only ever brought down from
the inside and the game does a fantastic
job of fleshing out their relationships
and why the world needs the avengers i
was also
one of those idiots that was angered
well well not angered but i just thought
it was stupid that kamala khan was going
to be the main character
in an avengers game and i'm so glad that
i was proven wrong as she's the perfect
person to follow her powers work
brilliantly
and seeing the avengers through the eyes
of someone who marvels
them as much as we do is really really
great
i bet ign wouldn't do a marvel pun that
bad now
she and bruce banner are a really great
team that i would never have put
together
but they work really well and slowly
they put everything back to how it was
they retrieve jarvis meet tony at an
incredible mission at his mansion
and discover the resistance led by hank
pym aka ant-man
after being guilt-tripped by one of the
resistance members
khan raids and aim prison but she's
captured and she wakes up to discover
tolerance partner moniker
discussing how the inhuman cure does not
work it's here that the pieces really
start to come together
and we discovered that she and tolton
who's pretty much modok at this point
have created machines known as adaptoids
they're pretty much like the sentinels
from the start of days of future past
and they can mimic inhuman powers we
learn that black widow has been
masquerading as an aim soldier for years
and that she was the one named tiny
dancer who contacted khan
after she learns of khan's capture she
rescues her and also takes monica
captive
aboard the chimera bruce attempts to
interrogate her but aim attacks which is
when thor joins their side
monika gets away but after a bit of
internal conflict
the group finally get to the bottom of
what happened on a day
it turns out that monica hired
taskmaster to steal a terrigen crystal
which triggered the chimeras autopilot
the reactor inside
actually started to pull up a massive
object buried beneath san francisco
and this would have caused the san
andreas faulty to stabilize and thus the
world would have been severely
devastated
captain america thus destroyed the
reactor and seemingly died
however we learned that his body was
taken by monica and placed onto a
satellite known as the ambrosia
it's here where monica makes the
adaptoids and using cap's body
namely his regeneration powers she's
been harvesting a formula from his blood
stock rescues cap but modok learns how
the formula is made
and he kills monica with a lethal dose
of it angered that there's no cure for
him and wanting revenge for looking like
crank from the ninja turtles
he decides to destroy all super powered
people on earth
he launches warships which will disperse
dark terrigen all over the world
and this will wipe out the inhumans
he'll probably start to feel better
about himself
but the avengers want to stop him
because they don't want him getting a
big head
hey having that now we learned that
modok wanted to create a world in which
he could control the superpower
but instead he created the inhumans and
he sees this as a great failure that he
must correct
the avengers launch an attack on his
compound and fight through his forces
until they get to modoc
he unleashes a cree sentry which we
learn was actually the object that the
reactor started to pull up
the group battle it out with him and he
enters the cree century and starts to
overpower it
which is when kamala steps forward to
take it down khan uses all of her
abilities to grow into a giant
and after mastering her powers she's
finally able to destroy it
modok falls into the sea and seemingly
dies but you know what
i wouldn't mind seeing him back kamala
returns to her father as a hero
and even though he was worried about her
and just wanted her back
he allows her to join the avengers
though they agreed to keep it a secret
this ends the main game but as we're
dealing with marvel
we of course get some post-credit scenes
in the first one we learned that monica
actually survived the injection
and this is because she used an inhumans
cloning ability to copy herself
monica was secretly the big bad and was
even using modok as a lab rat to carry
out her experiments
with him gone she now steps in and takes
the position of scientist supreme
which will allow her to carry on her
work she's pretty much made an army of
herself
and will likely rule the company until
these are all stopped
her plans clearly alert the avengers as
in the final post-credits scene
maria hill informs them that she's
discovered what monika's plans are
since gaining the position of scientist
supreme monica has continued her
experiments into cloning
and even started to dabble in cosmic
energy we also see that a small part
emerges from the creased century
and then it launches into space so
what's going on
well aeons ago i don't know why i said
the word aeons never mind
aeons ago the cree launched their
centuries across the universe
attempting to find planets to conquer
because the one on earth was buried and
its pod didn't return
the alien race wouldn't have believed
that the planet was worth going to
however now that this spot is going back
it could alert the creed to the events
that have happened on the planet
this could open the door for ronin the
supreme intelligence
and even captain marvel which i think
would all be brilliant inclusions
the cree are some of the big bads in
marvel well depending on which ones you
run into
but hey they will likely be the villains
next time i would love to see them
attack the earth
and then have captain marvel brought in
to help the avengers take them down
i can see monica joining their forces
and judging off the hawkeye dlc that's
coming down the line
he may also be working with her we
obviously have a lot of dlc coming too
including the spider-man pack so there's
lots of directions that they can go into
i think those add-ons will involve the
group investigating monika's work
and they will likely discover that she's
building cosmic energy to potentially
work with the cree
now it is possible that this pod also
had modoc in it and that's one of the
theories that i've seen floating around
and potentially he could be going into
galactic to bring something back to take
monica and the avengers down
there are a lot of possibilities out
there and obviously i'd love to hear
your thoughts on it
now before we get into the review i just
want to let you know we're giving away a
free copy of the christopher nolan
collection to one random subscriber
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the game in
the comment section below the win is
going to be chosen at random on the 30th
of september and the set will be shipped
out from then to ever gets the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part okay
so what did i think of the game overall
well
i was one of those people that
absolutely hated the beta
i was a beta hater as you would say and
because of this
i just wasn't hyped for it at all i even
cancelled my pre-order at one point
but decided to get it anyway because
what can i say
i'm a marvel shill i'm kind of glad that
i did though as i really enjoyed playing
it
and though it does get a bit button
mashy at times
it's still a lot of fun now if you just
want a casual game that you can play the
story for
and then sell or move on to something
else then this
is for you however if you're looking for
a deeper experience
then it's probably not the game is full
of micro transactions to the point that
they should have called it avengers
spend the game
huh you're having that because you spend
a lot on the game and there's also bugs
that can
break it from time to time there were
points that i just wish that thanos had
dusted me
and yeah it wasn't fun to get to a point
and just have the game
suddenly give up on me the graphics are
also pretty so so
which is a shame because they had a big
opportunity to really make this game
look incredible
but i feel like they dropped the ball a
bit however this is a game that really
captures the feeling of the avengers
and as far as a first outing goes i did
really enjoy it
there are enough characters here to
really diversify the game to the point
that you can pretty much play it how you
want to
it's enjoyable just punching people in
the face it just depends on what kind of
experience you want
more than anything to me anyway i'm a
pretty casual gamer just because
i don't really have the time to to sit
and play things for 70 hours because of
work
and therefore i don't mind a quick
nine-hour campaign
that has a neat little story to it which
i think this does however
you want something that's going to be a
meaningful experience that you can play
for months and months then
this probably isn't for you i wouldn't
say that this game is the complete
disaster that it's getting made out to
be by some reviewers
but it also had the potential to do so
much more
and yeah it does feel a bit
disappointing sometimes i'm really
hoping that they deliver down the line
with the live service model they have
but only time will tell still if you
enjoy marvel
i'd say it's worth getting and it scores
a seven out of ten
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the game so make sure you comment
below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video and want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the first
three episodes of the boys which are
going to be linked at the end
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on a
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]